who wears the pants like that's a
financial thing that's a manly thing
it's a feminine thing who wears the
pants in the relationship so will you
recently got engaged i did yes five days
ago five days there's a dirty rumor out
there that fosh also got engaged
recently congratulations i don't know if
we have audio for a round of applause
it's true um i recently got divorced so
congratulations
so will who wears the pants in your
relationship
well i wear the pants
yeah she's a leader in her own right and
she does amazing things i mean you guys
if anyone sees who she is you can go to
my instagram and see she is a leader
she's a role model she's strong and
courageous
strong yeah ava is her name the
strongest and bravest woman i've ever
met in my life but in terms of a
relationship with a man and a woman the
man leads so what does it mean to wear
the pants and to lead in the
relationship what does that mean you
know i guess i wouldn't really use the
term wear the pants for either of us i
would just say you know the the man is
the one who leads the man is the one um
yeah she's just incredible
no no yeah even though you live in
hollywood the warner brothers logos
right now yeah yeah yeah exactly no the
man
what does that mean
it means the man is the leader the man
the woman is able to obviously put her
input and say things that she believes
in and be a support system for the man
but the man when it comes to decisions
about things he has to be someone who
says okay i'm going to make this
decision because i am the leader of the
household i am the leader of the family
the leader of the children the leader of
the house leader of of my my wife and
everything like that that that is what
the man how is ava going to get offended
if she hears this clip no of course no
because there's so many things where she
influences me and gives me advice on
things and we're a team obviously a
partnership yeah but in so much that i
think that in in our world we've lost
that mentality of the man the lead so
fast you agree why do you agree with
will um i do think that men are like
leaders and i think that they should be
leaders and providers for sure um
obviously like as a woman you support
your man and you give him some some
input
and um like that like you help him
behind the scene oh look there i am oh
gosh look at this oh yours is much
different than mine
now this is some oscar's warner brothers
exactly
and there she is
congratulations wow thank you
okay but you're saying that your man
wears the pants in the family he leads
my man is a leader for sure
she respects him because jordan peterson
talks a lot if you have a confident
woman she's really not going to respect
a man who's not who does not lead
exactly right so we're all in agreement
on this that the man needs to lead is
that what we're saying taylor do you
have any strong feelings on why a woman
needs to lead
uh i mean women
should be leaders but i think there is
that role in a functioning society that
men that men need to lead i think for
definitely for like intimate
relationships in marriage
i think that men have to be like
in the forefront of things for sure like
if you're like a smart woman and you're
like i guess independent or whatever you
have that for yourself i think that's
important too to be able to have
conversations and be intellectual and
things like that but like when it comes
to like family values
i think you have to just stand by your
man
yeah
yeah if they're if they're doing the
right things you know if they're doing
some shady [ __ ] no of course not yeah
but that's part of being a leader as a
man is doing the right thing yeah
integrity means doing the right thing
when no one's looking you have to be
that type of leader as a man within your
household for sure what do you think
adam yeah look uh i mean it's hard to
disagree with with everything we're
talking about um but i think it comes
down to the foundation of respect like
one of the reasons i i met fosh as i was
asking questions like what are you
looking for in a man
and you know obviously most girls will
say well i want to be attracted to the
guy obviously funny personality and then
the money conversation because you have
to make that money exactly english money
thank you and she said i think i'm not
gonna date a guy that doesn't make more
than me or it isn't successful this is
the whole hypergamy factor yeah but i
don't think it's like on a superficial
level i think like
if you can provide as a man and you like
you've shown that you can go out there
and get it and provide that makes me
very attracted to you and like um it
makes me respect you you get what i'm
saying so like that shows me something
like oh okay you can go out there and
you can do this so that makes me want to
be like oh yeah so is it income or is it
ambition that women are attracted to i
would say ambition incompetent if you're
competent and you go after it the money
comes first so it's kind of like that um
if you do well in life you will have
money so it's it kind of you know what i
mean it's definitely the competence for
me
what does competence mean
for a female
because men let me just say this men
i've had i've interviewed fresh and fit
rollo
their their take that's a little and
i've and i i must say for the most part
i tend to agree we don't really care
what our female does or what they make
as long as they make you happy and
they're your fulfilling relationship i
don't care if she makes 30 grand a year
or she's a teacher i don't care if she
makes 150 grand like this has come down
to the man needs to lead and be the
provider i mean you know like caveman
instincts but the word we just discussed
was what capable competent
what does that mean for for when women
look at a man oh he's competent oh your
girl's company or man is confident oh
okay what does that mean yeah well
especially in a capitalist society if
you're competent you're going after
things you may be an entrepreneur you
you feel confident to go after whatever
it is that you're doing and you're doing
it well and when you do things well and
you get recognition for it the money
comes and so sure that's it's like a
skit it's like a measuring scale the
money but do i just look at the money
no
[Music]
you